♪ (INSPIRATIONAL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
HASAN MINHAJ:
While I'm watching this live,
I'm like,
"This cannot be happening.
This cannot be happening."
JENNY YANG: I think
it just blew all of our minds
that we would see someone
that looked like my cousin
dominate on an NBA court.
SPEAKER:
It's the most impossible thing
I think I have ever witnessed
in my life.
(CROWD CHEERS)
When most Americans
think about Asians,
they think about dry cleaners,
they think about IT guys.
Small, passive,
diminutive, unathletic.
The stereotyping, the derision
are so rampant.
You don't think no Asian kid
that's this size
is gonna be dunking.
JEREMY LIN: This is who I am,
this is what I'm capable of.
All you guys need to do
is watch and see.
SPEAKER 2:
This kid came out of nowhere,
started balling, like, for real.
LISA LING: It wasn't just
Asian people talking about it.
Everybody was talking about it!
TYSON CHANDLER: The Lakers
came in with the idea that
we're gonna end this fairytale,
we're gonna end it tonight.
YANG: But Jeremy
just kept making shots.
He gave all y'all
what y'all wanted to see.
MINHAJ: Is this
the other plot of Space Jam?
Like, whose superpowers
did Jeremy Lin steal?
SPEAKER 3: Yo,
this dude scored 38 points!
SPEAKER 4:
At The Garden, at the Metro.
The biggest thing
Linsanity brought was hope.
It inspired people.
LING: The last few years,
Asian Americans have just
gotten beaten down.
And when I think back
on Linsanity,
I long to feel those moments
of just pure joy and unity.
MINHAJ: This moment,
it broke the matrix for us.